being Eddie Murphy's older brother did
you always want to be in Show Business
no you didn't always want to be in Show
Business no but you know we used to play
a game when he was little it was cool
this is my show
and uh what we would do is we would
stand in front of the mirror and whoever
was in front of the mirror the other one
would push that gas this is my show and
I pushed him out the mirror no it's my
show in a way that's been your whole
life he became a superstar yeah what
were you doing no when we were playing
that game I was just playing the game I
wasn't even thinking about he was for
real he was for real oh he's always been
for real 100 so what were you doing when
he was you know this 17 year old kid
going to the comedy clubs and getting
arrested I was different were you really
were you in trouble with the law quite a
bit were you ever in prison though
Nassau County Jail was as far as it went
for me right and uh I you know I got my
life together after that right did your
brother help you with that like he made
you a bodyguard not at all what happened
was this uh when I
I was kind of I think what I really
think affected me the most was you know
when I was 10 years old my father was
murdered all right okay and uh I didn't
realize it but I guess it had an effect
on me and I became you know
Angry Angry Angry or whatever yeah you
know then we moved to a new town where'd
you move to Roosevelt oh yeah oh I
didn't know that
and move the Roosevelt and then you know
I was at outcast in Roosevelt because I
was from Brooklyn right so then you know
I banded together with because that year
for some reason there was a lot of
people like a mass migration people from
the city moving out to the island right
so we all became a crew right all the
new guys well the new guys became a crew
because it was like oh yeah you want to
jump me because I'm from Brooklyn where
I hear my boy from the Bronx my other
boy from Harlem right now jump us it was
it's a very tough neighborhood having
grown up there right I I certainly
couldn't join any gang but I would have
in a minute had I been able to because I
would have received some protection I
know what you mean I was a I was a guy
who was immediate friends an outcast and
also a
did they ever catch your dad's Killers
uh the woman that killed my father I was
a woman yeah wow why did a woman kill
yourself
no they weren't together okay and it's
one of the oldest stories in the books
you know I tell my kids man hey man if
the girl is mad Don't Close Your Eyes
so you so so watching Eddie's success
how to be Bittersweet for a guy like you
because you're losing that bittish sweet
it was I can't tell you better proud I
am about my brother there's nothing
better about it be honest for a minute
I'm being totally honest it must have
been I'm explaining you why I wasn't all
right
I know my family's history from the boat
when they first brought us over here
right so
to see someone rise above that okay
because before my generation or whatever
I can't look back and go yeah you know
my uncle went to Harvard and then he was
this right no we was you know regular
American black people you know
struggling and getting you know get get
ahead and then one of us broke through
the first time I seen my brother perform
on stage uh the feeling that he gave me
um I could still feel that feeling right
now by the way sometimes it gives me
goosebumps and I seen the crowd react to
him and you know yeah I'm very proud I
feel your brother
is probably the greatest stand-up I've
ever seen
now I'm not going to disagree with you
on that and I've told Eddie that but
Eddie but Eddie uh made you his
bodyguard in a way well you know when I
came out the Navy that's all I was
actually qualified to do you know I was
right when I was in the Navy I worked in
the boiling room right so you got out
and they didn't have a boiling room
where he needed
employees so you get out of the Navy
your brother's a superstar superstar
You're The Bodyguard brother and
everyone looks at you like oh man he's
just there because Eddie's giving him a
job I mean uh I never went to my brother
and asked him for anything nothing
nothing he put you on salary my brother
put me on salary he gave me a job I
didn't ask him to give me a job right he
asked me do I want to work for him right
and you all you got to do is hang out
and protect Eddie yeah but what happened
was I was overzealous so and what
happened what does that mean I was
jumping on people from not laughing you
know
did you start kicking some ass and
everything have you said anything wrong
you know what to an extent I'm still
like that I'm very protective of both of
my younger brothers right
um so if I said something bad you would
jump on my ass
and that's why I've grown since then I
don't I don't you know I can handle it
with my mouth so did they have to talk
so did they have to call you aside and
say you can't Eddie sat me down one day
and said look man you know I really like
you know having you around
you're a good guy when you stomp that
guy just because you know he didn't
laugh right so what happened but so did
you get in trouble uh with the law when
you started to be an overly aggressive
bodyguard yeah man it was some stuff
that went down where you know they had
to leave La for a while well now you're
getting some real Fame oh yeah people
are recognizing you real people are
recognizing that you're funny so how did
you make that move how did you hook up
with Chappelle and how did you start uh
being known as a funny guy on your own
right the way I hooked up with Chappelle
had nothing to do with being funny it
was from the movies that I had done and
the movies that I had done I was I had
been in comedies but they always would
hire me to be the mean guy right and I
kept going after that but they was
always casting me in comedy so how how
bad could you really be looked at if
it's a comment if you know so but I kept
doing and doing it and it ended up with
me eventually going to Japan
foreign